one in a hundred children are born with
a heart defect
and the children's heart foundation here
locally helps families
of young people in our community living
with heart problems
tomorrow you can help their mission it's
the 18th annual
walk with the heart of a child and
everyone is invited to come out to craig
ranch park
tomorrow morning for the fun these
fundraisers are the backbone of what
they do at the foundation
we're coming out of a really stressful
year
our state shut down the same week that
we were happy
that we had our scheduled walk last year
so
this walk this year is very meaningful
not only to the families that we serve
but it's bringing our community together
melissa cipriano there the executive
director of the foundation
says that boy they are really looking
forward to this walk
i'll be out there along with steph
mckenzie from 97 won the point
the walk is tomorrow at craig ranch park
in north las vegas
check-in starts at 9 a.m and the one
mile fun walk
kicks off at 9 45. you can register and
get more information
at chfn.org we hope to see you there
all coveted restrictions and safety
measures will be in place
to keep everybody safe nate